the Santa Claus came out back in 1994 so
while no one from a cast actually became
Santa they have definitely aged keep
watching for how the cast of this
holiday classic looks now
at the time the Santa Claus was released
Tim Allen was already an established
star in the Realms of stand-up comedy
and sitcoms thanks to his hit series
Home Improvement planes got Calvin
quickly made him a film star something
that was cemented just a year later by
his voice role as Buzz Lightyear and
Pixar's debut feature Toy Story to
Infinity
the Santa Claus kicked off a string of
comedy films for Alan throughout the
1990s and early 2000s including jungle
to Jungle for richer or poorer and
Galaxy Quest after Home Improvement
ended in 1999 he continued acting in
films including the two Santa Claus
sequels in 2002 and 2006 until his
return to sitcom stardom in 2011 with
Last Man Standing Allen continues to
play his signature role of the lovably
in over his head dad as he in years
three decades of acting work and after
six seasons on ABC Last Man Standing has
a new home at Fox as of the fall of
2018. he also went on to voice Buzz
Lightyear on all four of the Toy Story
films
Charlie Calvin is an eager young man
whose only wish is to get right to work
helping his father be the best Santa he
can be this includes even going as far
as journeying to the North Pole to help
the elves design and build a new sleigh
Eric Lloyd who played Charlie shared a
similar work ethic throughout the 1990s
though he's best known for his role in
the Santa Claus and its two sequels
Lloyd has plenty of other acting credits
to his name dating back to H2 back then
he appeared as young Kevin on The Wonder
Years After the Santa Claus came along
and made him even more visible he
continued to work steadily for the rest
of the decade playing a young Bruce
Wayne in Batman and Robin and Landing a
recurring role on the Christina
applegate-led sitcom Jesse these days
Lloyd spends much of his time behind the
camera after graduating from Chapman
University with a degree in Film
Production he co-founded LP Studios a
production and post-production Company
for the film and music Industries his
work includes everything from sound
mixing to cinematography
David kromholtz's screen acting career
was just beginning when he landed the
role of Bernard he's the grumpy but
ultimately compassionate head elf who
guides Scots and Charlie through their
North Pole journey and ultimately
provides a way for the father and son to
stay in contact at the end of the film
krumholtz's acting career gained
considerable steam throughout the 1990s
and 2000s so much so that while he
reprized his role for the Santa Claus 2
he was unable to return for The Santa
Clause 3 The Escape Clause because of
another commitment
where'd he go
that commitment was krumholtz's other
best known role mathematician Charlie
Epps on the hit CBS drama numbers a role
he played for five years and nearly 120
episodes to this day grumholtz continues
to work regularly in both film and
television more recently appearing in
the TV series living biblically and the
deuce and films like The Ballad of
Buster Scruggs
and acclaimed talent in the United
States as well as her native Canada
Wendy crewson worked regularly
throughout the 1980s in film and
television and she landed the role of
Laura Miller in the Santa Claus like her
frequent scene partner Judge Reinhold
she grew from non-believer to supporter
and Ally and Scott Calvin's Santa
adventures and the film's popularity
allowed her to return for both of its
sequels crewson also continued to work
regularly after the Santa Claus and
gained higher profile roles in American
film and television because of it among
her other major credits after the film
are Air Force One starring Harrison Ford
and the Canadian Supernatural medical
drama Saving Hope in which she
co-starred for Five Seasons between 2012
and 2017. in 2016 the Canadian screen
Awards presented her with its Earl Gray
award recognizing her lifetime of
contributions to television in Canada
Judge Reinhold was already an
established name as an actor by the time
the Santa Claus was made but unlike Tim
Allen who was on the rise Reinhold had
already faced a decade of ups and downs
in the film industry after hits like
Beverly Hills Cop and Fast Times at
Ridgemont High he'd also dealt with
major flaps like vice versa and had
retreated back into supporting roles the
Santa Claus introduced him to a new
audience and as Dr Neil Miller he was
beloved and brought back for both of the
film sequels since the Santa Claus
Reinhold has also continued to work
steadily in film and television
including appearances in the series
Arrested Development and the 2017 film
Bad Grandmas as well as many other guest
star appearances
like Alan Lloyd crewson and Reinhold
Peter Boyle also has the distinction of
appearing in all three films and the
Santa Claus trilogy but unlike them he
played different roles Boyle whose film
acting career was already well
established in nearly three decades old
at the time of the original film played
Scott's boss Mr Whittle in the first
film it was then brought back to play
father time in both the Santa Claus 2
and The Santa Clause 3. Boyle's career
before the Santa Clause was already well
established and included celebrated
roles and everything from Young
Frankenstein to taxi driver but it was
what happened after the first film was
released that made him a household name
Boyle was cast as Frank Barone on the
massively successful sitcom Everybody
Loves Raymond for which he received
seven consecutive Emmy Award nominations
for outstanding supporting actor in a
comedy series unfortunately Boyle passed
away on December 12 2006 at the age of
71. check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more Looper videos
about your favorite celebrities are
coming soon subscribe to her YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]